well you know we have a country that
only one of 10 nursing homes meet basic
federal standards only one of 10 that
means nine of ten do not so if you're
going to have dignified care one of the
first things you have to do is to make
the nursing homes much more decent than
they presently are then we need to
develop home care programs and the co
the unpaid in-home care givers are often
wonderful people but they're poorly
treated they often get no health
benefits themselves no pension benefits
very low pay and yet everybody says they
want to remain in their own home as long
as possible so we're going to have to
have a better trained and better paid
workforce to take care of people say
good order for really really want to
have a dignified care of
well stuff because the reimbursements
are not good and especially in medicine
what happens is the average student that
graduates medical school has about 150
thousand dollars in debt so it's very
attractive to get into especially where
you have a procedure where you can
quickly make money like you can get they
say five six hundred dollars for doing a
colonoscopy you get maybe a hundred
dollars for seeing an older person for
an hour so it's not an attractive field
as it now stands for many people on the
other hand there are those that do care
deeply about old people and we have to
figure out ways to encourage them down
to the field
fruitlessly the government should be the
private sector the nonprofit sector and
I think more and more we have to build a
strategy that builds both homes and home
care so that more and more people can be
cared for at home not just in the
nursing home or the Home for the Aged